okay meanwhile the other big story of
the day it is amazing i will say
america's love affair with dogs is
pretty astonishing
the way that it works in the united
states is that the taliban
are um the taliban kill a bunch of
american soldiers and behead a bunch of
people and take over an entire country
and americans are like mildly upset
about that or pretty upset about that
if we leave the dogs behind that's a
major issue okay in similar ways
so anthony fauci lied about gain of
function research
and he defined gain of function research
as gain of function within an animal
right not gain of function meaning a bat
virus is now transmissible among humans
he says that's not gain of function then
there's a letter that just came out
from eco health alliance admitting that
the wuhan institute of virology was
making bat viruses transmissible to
humans by testing it in mice
and so it turns out they were lying the
whole time so anthony fauci is out there
defending himself on the charge that he
lied in front of congress
i obviously totally disagree with
senator paul he's absolutely incorrect
neither i nor if dr francis collins the
director of the nih lied or misled about
what we've done the framework under
which we have guidance about the conduct
of research that we fund the funding at
the wuhan institute was to be able to
determine what is out there in the
environment in bat viruses in china okay
so he's still fitting about this people
care a lot less about this
than the fact that he was experimenting
on puppies now isn't that a bond villain
twist it turns out that the guy who is
funding
bat coronaviruses at the woohon
institute of virology for gain of
function research
right and
this is not to suggest that fauci funded
the creation of coven 19 specifically
because the strains of virus that were
being researched under the nih grant
were different
but the guy who was funding the wuhan
institute of biology and money is
fungible the guy who's done a horrible
job throughout this pandemic while
trying to control all of our lives
it turns out that also he had greenlit
experimentation on puppies
a little too on the nose the writing
this year is really on the nose i gotta
say this year so we're we're in season
what six now of trump
and uh and the writing has gotten
progressively worse like most series
once you get past season three the
writing really starts to collapse and
the writing this season has just been
really on the nose according to yahoo
news dr fauci is facing a demand from
lawmakers on both sides of the aisle to
divulge information regarding the
alleged use of an experimental drug on
puppies
democratic and republican lawmakers sent
a letter friday to joe biden and the
niaid requesting they share information
regarding the alleged infection of 44
beagle puppies with parasites in order
to test an experimental drug on them
according to the hill
the letter written by republican south
carolina representative nancy mace and
23 other lawmakers says we write with
grave concerns about reports of costly
cruel and unnecessary taxpayer-funded
experiments on dogs commissioned by the
niaid apparently
cortex cordectomies were performed on
six to eight-month-old dogs apparently
this is a devocalization it involves
splitting a dog's vocal cords in order
to prevent them from barking helling or
crying
is opposed by the american veterinary
medical association and the american
animal hospital association
and apparently they're requesting
answers on how many drugs have been
performed on dogs since the beginning of
2018.
the uh the original report is a slightly
more graphic
apparently the parasites with which they
were infected
were really like very very unpleasant
apparently they're characterized as
cruel puppy experiments
according to the white coat waste they
said quote our investigators show that
fouchy's nih division shipped part of
375 800 grand to a lab in tunisia to
drug beagles and lock their heads in
mesh cages filled with hungry sand flies
so the insects could eat them alive
they also locked beagles alone in cages
in the desert overnight for nine
consecutive nights to use them as bait
to attract infectious sand flies
so basically they were reenacting the
nicolas cage scene from
wicker man
and they're like locking the beagle's
head in cages
which is just
horrifying with nih funding it will be
kind of amazing if what brings anthony
fauci down is that he was mean to dogs
not you know the four million dead
people
across the across the world thanks to
the wuhan institute of virology and also
not his complete failures during the
pandemic
but americans do love their dogs that is
for sure meanwhile on the coven front
i i will admit that the the bond
villains are now coming out of the
woodwork so the new the new zealand
prime minister jacinda ardern right who
is getting all sorts of plaudits for
locking down her entire
country which is basically
what is the population of new zealand
the new zealand population is
something like five million
and like a couple million hobbits and
some sheep so she locked down her entire
country was in ireland they didn't get a
big outbreak and she was celebrated for
this because as it turns out when you're
an island with five million people a
couple million hobbies of sheep it's a
lot easier to lock down and then she
didn't vaccinate anybody and then there
was an outbreak there anyway so now they
have vaccine passports over there that
they're really pushing and she just
admits straight up that she's trying to
create two classes of citizens
so you basically said this is going to
be like well it's almost like you
probably don't see like this the two
different classes of people if you're
vaccinated or if you're unvexited you
have all these rights if you are
vaccinated that is what it is so yep
yep yep and she's smiling while she says
yep if you're vaccinated you have all
these rights if you're unvaccinated you
don't have any rights man when they say
the quiet part out loud and they
celebrate it
just demonstrates that that if you have
populations that are basically willing
to concede to anything the so-called
experts tell them they will do anything
to you they will do anything to you
so long as you decide to give up liberty
in favor of
a little temporary safety things tend
not to work out particularly well
especially when it turns out that your
experts are just lying to you
and which they are i mean it is amazing
every time the experts are asked about
why they got things wrong they just have
no good answer rachelle linsky over at
the cdc was asked over the weekend about
the simple fact that everybody from
anthony fauci to rochelle balensky to
everybody else were like we can't have
stadiums full of people stadiums full of
people are bad and we've had stadiums
full of people for months at this point
no major outbreaks at any of the
stadiums wellenski was asked about it
and she still won't back off the idea
that it's a really bad thing
what does it tell you that there have
not been spikes in most of these
communities when you have people crowded
into football or baseball stadiums
we would still encourage people who are
unvaccinated to wear a mask in those
situations but given that these games
are outdoors that tends to be a much
safer environment
well then maybe you should have said
that but you won't because it's about to
control it's not about fixing anything
how's this for a title ben shapiro show
subscriber destroys like button with
clicks and logic i'd watch that make it
happen gang